all right thank you so much jc everyday
heroes like healthcare professionals
deserve our support and honor daily
especially right now
as they help communities battle cope at
19. channel 8 has partnered up with
southwest medical to salute
shine light on and spread joy to our
local superheroes take a look
hello ladies welcome to las vegas now hi
hi i'm so excited to honor you both this
is our southwest medical salute to
superheroes and that is our healthcare
heroes so
how do you feel about that you guys are
being honored today um
very surprised yes very surprised
you guys seriously you're the work that
you do every day is so appreciated and
so
needed um in our community and beyond so
first let's have you introduce
yourselves and tell us what you do
okay um my name is nikitake i'm the rn
manager for
nortonia urgent care and nellis
convenient care with southwest medical
and i'm jackie cordo i am the
mammography supervisor
here at southwest medical and i'm in
charge of all
the all 10 sites day-to-day for me is
clinic person-to-person
clinics have been open every day
throughout all of covid
we're there seven to seven seven days a
week um
we've never shut down we never cut back
hours or anything like that so we've
been
front lines from the start which has
been
a challenge but um really pushed the
teams to come together
during this time and i'm really proud of
the work that we were able to do
every day at our at our sites we're
doing screening mammograms for
so those are patients that are that come
in for their annual mammograms routine
mammograms and then
over at our diagnostic sites you know
those are the patients that come
in for a little bit more uh detailed
types of uh
uh exams what creates a good day
where you guys work especially during a
pandemic
a good day for me is a day that made a
difference that we were open that we
were there for somebody to come in
and get seen beautiful in your answer
yeah and so so for me it's the same
thing just seeing all the patients still
coming in
you know with everything going on a lot
of people are scared
um they just don't know what's happening
you know and so
when they come in especially getting a
mammogram like a lot of women are scared
you know because you know they hear
stories or whatever but
for me what's satisfying is seeing a
patient
come in and then when they walk out that
door they're like big old smile on their
face and they're just like oh my gosh
thank you so much
yeah and it's also the the look of
relief on their faces right yes
yes definitely when they're like oh
that's it
and we're like yeah that's it so that's
that's
that's really good awesome such
rewarding work for you guys and
is there any information that you'd like
to share with our viewers just moving
forward after they see this
what should they remember um
remember you know southwest medical
where we're still open we have the
urgent care locations
we have the virtual platform with um
with now clinic
we're still open for routine care
preventative care anything they need um
come on down congrats and thank you
again to our local superheroes nikki and
jackie of southwest medical
we'll be right back here in las vegas
now